c'est ce qu'a estimé un rapport
sénatorial qui préconise une loi sur les
sols pollués
la france compte plus de trois cent
vingt mille anciens sites industriels ou
miniers sur son territoire la
rapporteure et sénatrices de lod
gisèle jourda met en garde contre les
tonnes de déchets toxiques qui
s'accumulent dans les sols la commission
d' enquête a même mis en avant l'
impuissance de l'état contre ce problème
pour lutter contre le manque de
transparence et de responsabilité
les sénateurs ont proposé de changer la
législation en créant un droit à
l'information du public sur la pollution
des sols et leurs effets sur
l'environnement
une loi qui serait identique à celle sur
la surveillance de la pollution de l'air
un appel à la prévention a également été
fait le rapport préconise d'établir une
cartographie nationale des risques
sanitaires et environnementaux liés aux
pollutions des sols pour établir la
liste des zones à risques la commission
denquête recommande de mobiliser une
enveloppe de 50 millions d'euros
elle propose également la création d'un
fonds national de réhabilitation des
sites pollués
avec un budget de 75 millions d'euros
par an